Want to know what's heating up in theaters this weekend?
The fate of the universe lies in your shoulders.
So we are saving the Galaxy again?
Yep!
The team is back for more space action in "Guardians of the Galaxy volume 2".
- I'm Groot?
- Noooooo!!!
Why can't you just be a lesbian?
Because she's not a lesbian, mom. She's a boy.
In "Three generations" a young woman's decision forces a family to come together.
Something's got to change.
I'm done with being an exception.
Everybody knows I'm an idiot, all right?
Come back, I'm a moron!
Debra Winger stars in "The Lovers" about a married couple falling in love right before their divorce
So you're screwing your wife now?
As if...?
See what's hot in theaters with this week's fanticipation.
So what's your weekend to get going to be?
Let us know by commenting. See you next time on weekend ticket.